hello and welcome to footnotes as per
the usual I'm here to recap the most
ravishing language and ideas from the
last week of Wired first up today
unmitigated technophobia gadget labs
Christina Bonnington is spending a month
using only her smartphone to pay for
things and in a recent piece she dropped
a very scary word around these parts let
so I let it is someone who shuns
technology this term traces back to an
eighteenth-century Englishman who
probably never existed Ned Ludd so the
story went that Ned's boss told him his
work sucked so Ned naturally destroyed
the stocking frame he was using because
Ned was totally oh gee a few decades
later this knitting machine became the
favorite targets of the Luddites but
contrary to popular belief they weren't
protesting technology per se their
movement arose in response to unfair
labor practices manufacturers were using
increasingly efficient machinery and
we're hiring increasingly under skilled
and underpaid workers this may be
familiar to you if you happen to be
alive right now let I'd protest often
turn violent and the reaction was swift
the British government made the
destruction of manufacturers capital a
capital offense it's unclear if they
realized what an excellent pun that is
but if luddites were going to get
executed for this they may has well have
looked good doing it so they often
crossdressed 134 this claims that the
men were trying to assume the energy of
the unruly woman whatever the hell that
means no matter the reason I just hope
they scored some sweet threads before
destroying the machines that made them
that's just cross-dressing 101 next up
an electric car named Tesla and a man
named Tesla our own Damon labyrinth took
a spin and not just any Tesla Model S
but the personal Tesla of Elon Musk the
company's founder and CEO I just hope
that Damon didn't monkey around with
Elon seat settings and turn up the radio
really loud before we
in the car anyway the Tesla is named
after the great Nikola Tesla perhaps the
most underappreciated inventor in
American history these Barry lights are
on because of Tesla and are now off
because of Wired's smartass script
supervisor Tesla started work in America
with Thomas Edison who offered him what
would today be over a million dollars to
make improvements to the direct current
electric system it was direct current or
DC that Edison had heavily invested in
Tesla made the improvements but Edison
refused to pay saying that Tesla didn't
understand the American brand of humor
you see Tesla was born in modern-day
croatia where they enjoy slapstick humor
not screwing people out of money so
Tesla gave Edison the metaphorical bird
and went off to make the rival system
alternating current or AC more
commercially viable Edison was like oh
no you didn't and started a smear
campaign in which he publicly
electrocuted an elephant named Topsy
with alternating current obviously
pachyderms didn't appreciate Edison
sense of humor either but that Joker's
direct current could only travel a few
miles before requiring a substation
among other limitations so alternating
current eventually won out with AC our
grid it became far less complicated and
expensive and that meant fewer jobs so
let its were like oh no you didn't
you